at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking organisms living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealth front as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of now I do have to
read a mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there is the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller and I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99designs com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free $99
upgrade on your first design that's
99designs dot-com a forward slash Tim
check it out
Millia boon has been called the Michael
Jordan of obstacle course racing since
the sports inception she's a mast and
she's laughing more than 30 victories
and 50 podiums her major victories
include the Spartan Race World
Championship 2003 Spartan Race Series
point champion 2013 and 2015 and she's
the only three-time winner of the
world's toughest mutter 2012 14 and 15
she's also a three-time finisher of the
death race in Davos an ultra running in
all of her her spare time which I'm sure
is massive and has a a flourishing and
high-velocity career to boot Amelie and
welcome to the show thank you yeah I
appreciate you taking the time and I
thought we could start with a photo so I
was doing research for this and went to
your website which is Millie boo and
racing yes calm and can you describe the
the photo that takes up most of the real
estate on that page well so the website
needs a bit about dating I'm not a great
website person so if you know if anybody
wants to volunteer be my guest but it's
a picture of me I'm in the middle of
barbed wire and I'm crawling on my hands
and knees and I'm just kind of looking
around semi perplexed and to me that
just kind of encapsulates everything
that I do I'm bleeding from you know my
knees my elbows and it's just crawling
through the mud having a good time a
microcosm the face of obstacle course
racing exactly it's not pretty
we met through Scott connealy who is
putting together may be finished by the
time people see this and available rise
of the suffer fests so sufferfest Emeth
mentioned the blood you mentioned the
dirt the barbed wire uh maybe we can
explain to people who are unfamiliar
what obstacle course racing is with the
example of the world's toughest Muhtar
you describe what on earth that is well
so that's kind of like the extreme of
obstacle course racing right um but in
general I mean I think people have been
familiar with Spartan races with
mutters you see people jumping over fire
and crawling under barbed wire and it's
just you know you're running along and
you have a wall to climb and you're you
know jumping through mud and you're
using everything that you have like it's
just completely physical experience but
so I got involved back in 2011 when I
ran a tough matter with friends and then
signed up for
there was this race that was announced
called world's toughest mutter and
they're like you for 24 hours are gonna
run as many laps of a course a Tough
Mudder course as you can and it's gonna
be in December in New Jersey and balmy I
was like hmm man I can't think of it
anywhere I'd rather go than New Jersey
in December and so a bunch of us signed
I think a thousand people signed up for
this like and nobody had any idea what
they were getting into you know we had
all run like a Tough Mudder or run a
Spartan Race but nobody had ever really
done it for 24 hours so we went out that
day and people were trying to figure out
like how do you stay warm for 24 hours
when you're in and out of water and um
you know and it's December and it's New
Jersey so we decided that we would wear
wet suits or that wet suits would be the
way and to stay warm and other people
former triathletes were like oh there's
no way you can run for 24 hours in a wet
suit you'll die you know like the how
your thermoregulation will be all off or
whatever but we did and okay and like
halfway through so we got all go out and
it's like 30 degrees outside New Jersey
after the first lap there about a
thousand people that start I'd say maybe
850 people dropped out I just love first
lap like like John and this is what like
an hour like a few hours into it
probably an hour and a half and I
remember going back in my tent and like
just shivering uncontrollably being like
what am i doing like what what is going
on here you know
you like would walk past like the the
Med tents and there were just people in
there like laying on cots they were
using like saline bags to like warm
saline to put under people's arms like
like armpits to keep them warm and so a
few of us decided to keep that we were
gonna keep going and I think by you know
the night descended on us it was like
2:00 a.m. we're like walking through the
wot wading through water and like there
was ice forming we're like you know
breaking holes in the ice and I'm
sitting here being like what am i doing
like what am i doing but at the same
time was having so much fun and out of a
thousand people that started that race
12:00 finished and I was one of two
women yeah so that was that was the
start of it all and I for some unknown
reason I remember when I finished that
race 24 hours later I was like never
again never again and then like two
weeks later I'm like sign me up what's
what's next
sign me up and the the drive to do this
type of thing there's so many different
approaches I could take to try to
dissect this but are your parents very
surprised not surprised at all or
somewhere in between um I would say
somewhere in between because so I've
always been like the high achiever type
a you know um you know I I wouldn't be
able to top my class I wouldn't be you
know like graduating summa [ __ ] laude and
going to law school and everything like
that so I think I read there one of your
law school classmates said that you
would find a way to be competitive or to
win in anything if it were folding
laundry or otherwise oh yeah like I was
like in law school the scent of like my
exercise is like getting on the
elliptical you know like everybody else
and I would like find a way to compete
next then the person like on the
elliptical next to me but so I think the
drive and the determination like that
doesn't phase you know like my parents
like par for the course but in terms of
like how it
manifested itself because I've always
been kind of like a creature routine and
like I don't like surprises and I want
to be able to like like plan everything
and know everything and with obstacle
course racing it's so unknown when you
go out there like for the most part when
I first started like they won't even
show you wouldn't see a course map so
you want to know what was out there
and so I think that part they're kind of
like wow or like when I would sign up
for the death race and they would be
like 72 hours in the wood it's and you
don't know what you're gonna be doing
but have at it and so that was very kind
of like a typical personality for me
where did you grew up I grew up in
Portland Oregon in Portland and what did
your parents do growing up um so my dad
was an insurance like adjuster and my
mom was an environmental consultant
where did the competitive edge come from
I have not this is funny is like they
have no idea and like I have I think
it's got to be an eight to be totally
honest because my parents are always
like you can get C's that's fine or you
can you can play this sport or you don't
have to play this sport or as long as
you're happy you just do what makes you
happy and so there's tons more Portland
it was never like if you think of like
sage parents I was like the opposite of
that um so they were always telling me
to like calm down and take a break but
instead I just I worked well yeah do you
have siblings I do I have an older
sister older sister yeah is she also
competitively driven like you so I mean
we're pretty much like in terms of
personalities like opposites polar
opposites polar opposites she's
extremely successful but she came at
about it from a very like you know way
more laid-back and you know like low-key
approach what do you want to be when
you're a kid what did you want to be
when you grew up I wanted to be a lawyer
when I grow oh and you nailed it I know
I was one of those people that I was
like if I set my mind to something that
I'm going to do it so I would
lunch everyday when I was like at home
during the summer my mom and I would
always watch Perry Mason and I was like
man Perry Mason like being an attorney
he gets the bad guy to confess every
single episode that's gotta be cool
prisons great I remember it very amazing
so then I went to law school and
realized that's not actually what
happens and yeah more you were more
Perry Mason than a Matlock person so the
so you decide you want to be a lawyer
and did that change that waiver or did
that stick with you all the way up until
the point that you became a lawyer I
think it it pretty much and you know I
kind of thought of different things in
college I really got I really fell in
love with anthropology and primates and
so like you know I really loved studying
yeah monkeys and I thought for a pardon
me I'm like maybe I should go to
Madagascar and hang out with the lemurs
or I could go get a law degree hey a
double major in anthropology and
political science and then decided to
take the safe route and go with a lot of
great that was you Washington Washington
University Washington University that's
right and what did you do athletically
in high school or college so growing up
I was kind of like a I would say like a
jack-of-all-trades athlete and that I
played I was always on like a club team
like AAS a softball or club soccer you
know traveling basketball and so I play
year-round and I was always good I was
on like the competitive the
highest-level teams I was never like a
super standout all-star in any one
single sport so you know I played
year-round and I would show back and
forth from practice practice throughout
middle school in high school but I
started like pairing that down and I
actually as high school progressed I got
more and more into musical theater and
show choir and singing and I kind of
gave up sports and athletics so in
college I actually sang in
cappella group but I know sports no
sports in college as far it's
recreationally were you runner I would
go out and run to like stay in shape but
running in st. Louis kind of sucked so I
mean I just
hey who's either like hot and muggy or
like freezing cold so yeah I didn't
really didn't really do anything let's
so I'm gonna jump around a little bit
like momento but if we were to look at
say the world's toughest mutter yeah
what do your routines look like you said
you're a creature of habit as mi the
hours before the competition let's just
say like the day of order your routines
so I always get up like super early
before well I get up super early in
general every morning and what's super
early so my alarm typically goes off of
like right around 4:00 a.m. that's what
you didn't flinch on us we were talking
about Jocko willing the seal commander
I'm like any wakes up at four zero
response I'm like another one and so
actually on race days it's almost like I
sleep in a little bit when do when do
the races start typically they generally
will start we're all staff as matters a
little bit different that one starts at
2:00 in the afternoon now but um like
just a regular obstacle race would
generally be like 7:30 is the I got
already that starts at 2:00 p.m. so
let's use that example you wake up at
4:00 oh yeah then I Drive myself crazy
for the next however many hours
twiddling my thumbs what a what other
type of body prep or mental prep do you
do yeah I generally use the distraction
technique so I try to not think about
really cuz I can sit there and make
myself miserable over and over like like
picturing the race or whatever but I
find it helpful actually I actually do a
lot of work in the mornings before races
so I'll catch up on emails I'll do
things from like my attorney life
and then in terms like body prep I you
know I do a lot of like foam rolling
mobility things like that the older I
get the more I realize like I can't just
like jump out of bed in the morning and
like be surprised a chicken so you're 32
is that right yeah 32 32 I would imagine
you still have a couple of good years
left in you
but the mobility work that you do what
what what is that what does that
actually look like and in detail so I
generally carry like an arsenal of every
single like from a golf ball a lacrosse
ball a softball a foam roller and so I'm
really focused on loosening up hips
loosing up hamstrings and every single
different little torture device has you
know it's what the golf ball is for the
foot
um the lacrosse ball works for a while
on the glutes you know the softball is
great for the hamstrings so I'm just you
know getting the muscles kind of warmed
up and loosened and prepped and I do I
actually from a lot of various and
nagging injuries that I've always had I
have like little physical therapy
routines that I always do too you know
like to get your glutes activated and
things like what type of movements do
you do for glute activation there's this
fantastic exercise called Jane Fonda's
that Jeanne Vitus ever been these for
you like glute me man I should really
have leg warmers on right now you're
talking about is this like the bent leg
sort of the reverse thigh master pretty
much yes the reverse side master on your
side yeah yeah yeah and like variation
like doing fire hydrants like that you
you know like a dog lifting his legs
there's all super sexy things like if
you if you do them in a gym people are
like oh god knows that girl I tell you I
think that you probably get more
attention doing fire hydrants than I do
at least unless I'm in a gym in the
Castro which it might be a similar
experience and do use any other movie
a letís for prep do you use any stim to
use anything like that pre racers that
set aside for other other purposes
pre-race not so much no that's more like
recovery like recovery all like
compression boots and stem now our
compression boots the compression socks
are these actual boots the boots that
inflate oh right the air pressure
chambers that you know like kind of like
flush a supposedly flush out lactic acid
mm-hmm so that's and that's a post-race
that would be posterized yeah so let's
talk about post race then so in terms of
facilitating recovery so you've finished
the race yeah and is it true that you
have not slept for days on and after
Isis or is that an exaggeration oh it is
true so any long race that I've done
like world's toughest matters a 24-hour
race I've done other races that are
longer 48 that are 60 hours um and I
feel like it's just I can't sleep
afterwards and you feel like you should
be able to you're like wow I was just up
for three days straight running around
in the woods but my mind your body is so
physically exhausted but my mind is
still on so much like on overdrive that
I just I can't so I mean for instance
this year after worlds have this matter
we all went there was a group of staying
in a house sat around we're drinking
beers watching football game and I was
like man I should like really be getting
drunk right now or something like that
because like I'm drinking and I've been
running around and wetsuit all night
long I'm like I don't feel anything like
I don't feel any effects of the booze or
anything like that I was like it just
must be this adrenaline still pumping
through me did other people have the
same as similar experience for is that
unique to you no cuz everyone else just
kind of passed out and went to bed and
we ended when you cross the finish line
as such you're done what type of
recovery starts what are the what are
the
actions that you've taken the hours
following the race so I think one of the
most important things that people should
do that they don't is you have to stay
moving people want to finish a race and
especially a long one and just like lay
on a couch or go to sleep this is the
worst thing you can do because you're
gonna wake up and like not be able to
move anything so I generally try and
stay walking I try and stay active
you know I will hop again on like a foam
roll or something like that and try it
you don't want to be too aggressive
afterwards like you're not gonna like
hop on a softball and roll out your
glutes because like that's gonna hurt
really bad but then just just try and
stay active and that is in like the next
day too you know like gentle movement
and things like that to use do you are
you a proponent of
ice ice baths anything like that or not
if I can't so I mean look I'm not a
scientist whatever I all I know is what
works for me people have different
opinions if I can get into an ice bath I
will but it needs to be like immediately
so there have been races where there's
like a lake right next to me and I'm
like if it's cold enough then I'll just
go jump in the lake and kind of use that
as an ice bath but if you're waiting
like four or five hours I don't really
think it's gonna end up helping you in
the end and I want you to correct me if
I'm wrong 2012 world's toughest Mudder
how did you place I won for females but
I was second overall in 2012 second
place overall yeah how did that feel
so it was a really interesting race how
many competitors this was again there
were about 1200 people I believe is
generally every year so they're about
1200 people
it was once this one and they moved just
in November so it was supposedly a tiny
bit warmer but actually it wasn't it was
actually colder in 2012 then it was in
2011 um and I guess I didn't realize I
knew I was winning for women and at this
point we were about 24 hours or getting
close to the end and I was about 80 some
odd miles
and I was on the last lap but they're
like okay well you've won four women but
the guy that's winning is like nine
minutes ahead of you so we're on this
last lap you know going we'll end up
with 90 miles and there are all these
people from Tough Mudder headquarters
and like all these matters just like
yelling at me willing me to go on
because all they want me to do is to win
overall you know and you're so tired at
that point and like so kind of delirious
that I guess I didn't even realize like
the import of that situation like how
massive that would have been um because
I was just like leave me alone I heard
I'm tired
like I'm covered in like 10 like
millimeters of neoprene like I'm just
you know and I'm like I get it I'm
trying to move fast my body won't let me
but yeah so I ended up finishing about
nine minutes behind the male overall
winner and yeah so it was pretty it
didn't really hit me until like a day or
two later where I was like oh I was that
close oh okay so did you not did you
feel pride about finishing second
overall or were you just were you more
disappointed that you didn't finish
first overall and it's actually it's one
of these things now that when I race
it's almost I kind of look at the stand
it's cool to win you know as it as a
female you know be like oh I'm the
female winner but I'm more a look of
like I have a consistent goal of trying
place like top ten overall you know I
want to be I don't care sex gender like
I just want to be I want to you know
compete to the best you know overall
some and what the next female finisher
will place was she she actually in 2012
she was third oh no kidding yeah yeah
good for her was her into boobs in
Indiana black she's amazed she she's
amazing she's absolutely amazing and I'm
just like 46 year old as years old from
Australia 46 yeah just crushes what
abused yeah okay all my excuses just me
and she's like the nicest woman in the
entire world - so how does her strategy
for training or in the race itself
differ from younger younger competitor I
would say I think probably anything as
you get older you realize you you don't
go out as fast you know it's kind of
like as you age you're never gonna like
out sprint you know a 20-something year
old but you tend you have more mental
strength and more mental grit the older
you get just because you're like
whatever this isn't big deal you know
like you're more mature and you can deal
with pain and suffering so I think that
it's just kind of more like a slow and
steady you know and but just keep going
one foot in front of the other but to
that extend that's kind of how I operate
- is that I'm never I'm notoriously slow
out of the gate you know in in the
beginning of races I'm always like
struggling to catch up with everyone
which is why I like longer races um so
then you know but it's just kind of like
you know picking off one by one when
when you are actually before that this
is suffering let's talk about suffering
yeah I was just reading a letter of
Senecas who's that guy that's the bust
on the kitchen counter over there
related to I think it's on fasting and
celebration something related to that
but it talks about exposing yourself to
suffering right the along the lines of
the more the more you sweat during peace
the less you bleed during war right and
so I practice fasting among for many
reasons among those being practicing
hardship right so I can endure it in
other areas of my life do you do that in
other places in your life where you
deliberately expose yourself to
different types of pain or suffering as
a practice or is it limited to the
sacrifice I mean with the amount that I
raised
there's no suffering in that it's
sufficient I know I guess I can't do the
fasting thing oh god no I'm not good
with that
you're burning a lot more calories than
I am like if I don't eat every few hours
like it's it's trouble for anyone around
me but I I always try to train in less
than ideal conditions if I can because I
think that that adds a lot to it's super
easy to go out for a run when it's 70
degrees and sunny but like when I was
living in Chicago which I did for the
past six years if there was like a
windstorm or a thunderstorm I'm like let
me out you know like let me perfect time
to run perfect time to go run there was
one time that I am they had shut down
the lake front path because the waves
were coming over and I was like [ __ ] it
I'm running anyway apparently police
don't like that please tell me the
police tried to catch you on foot it was
a bicycle cop who I was only surprised
that he was like out in the weather as
well but yeah and he was like you can
this is shut down I'm just training no
big deal no big deal yeah did that do
that sway his no so training in less
than ideal conditions when you look back
at the races that you've around the
obstacle course races what has been the
most challenging obstacle for you and
what has been the most dangerous I would
say in terms of challenging I hope
didn't do so there's always I'm
notoriously awful at throwing a spear
and it's well known communities that I
can throw a spear to save my life
and so in Spartan races there's always a
spear throw and it actually just cost me
like tons of different races
and it's funny because like it's one of
those things that if you practice you
would probably be pretty good at it but
like puzzled right now okay like super
[ __ ] laude you know you know like ace
lawyer like world champion racer
okay so continue not to interrupt it
seems like the I thing you would sit
down and study and master you would
think so I actually think that playing
softball my entire life kind of screwed
me because I would like try and throw it
like you throw a softball which under
the other hand speaker no no but come on
the pitching does is completely
different right I'm referring to the
pitching folks don't get don't get it
don't get all riled up so that's always
been it's always been a challenge for me
and I finally figured it out but it's
one of those things that like it's a
it's such a silly thing to struggle with
I think um but I guess that also could
be the most dangerous because if you
miss a spear throw and somebody's around
no I'm joking but there are some in
terms of danger for obstacles like there
are times where I'm sitting there being
like why hasn't somebody died and I take
that back that's really bad custom eight
did die um but uh yeah but dangerous
part yeah you know when you're when
you're writing for 24 hours especially
like really long and you're like
climbing super tall things like in the
middle of the night I'm always thinking
they're mean like man one misstep and
I'm falling backwards and I'm you know
and I've taken some big diggers off the
walls just because you're so tired you
just big diggers meaning offal Falls you
know how then these are walls that
you're climbing over similar to a
military obstacle course yeah yeah how
tall are they um they vary um you know
some are eight feet some are 10 feet
some or twelve feet
some have ropes to help you up them you
know others you know there's big like
kind of like ladders
you know like military tackle adders you
know that like climb
at all climbing out of water so there's
one time I think it was in 2012 world's
toughest mother she climbed one of those
out of a lake and it was like 20 feet up
but it was in the middle of the night it
was like frozen and so you're like it's
like iced over and you're like I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die but yeah so there's
all these little dangers and people need
to talk about the electricity involved
in in tough mudders which is like a very
disconcerning because I've been hit so
hard sometimes that I've like blacked
out from the electricity yeah you
describe this this obstacle to folks
yeah so well so there's a couple
variations of it but basically there's
these wires hanging the worst variation
was called electric eel and you crawl
through water that's about like 2 3
inches deep and there's wires hanging
down over your head and so you're you're
like army crawling through it and your
head is hitting these wires and there
will occasionally will like shock you
Zacky oh and it is it 10,000 volts I
don't I don't there's the difference we
do fold in some wattage and I don't
really understand what it is but one
will kill you in one won't so this is
supposedly the stuff that won't kill you
but if you get hit in just the right way
and you're in water like I got hit so
hard and like I my face smack down
through the water and hit my head and
then I like blacked out I started
crawling the wrong way and now it's one
of those things that like once you like
do like that it's like something like
that happens to you you just have like
this insane fear of it you know and so
it's the worse for me now like trying to
press you just have the trepidation yeah
beforehand yeah
well the people who get injured or even
the fatalities what are what are the
most common causes honestly I think the
vast majority of injuries are things
like rolled ankles broken ankles you saw
what you would expect what you would
expect I mean I don't think they've
never and the you know the one the one
unfortunate death that I think that we
know
that have occurred or deaths that have
occurred have been like you know heat
stroke dehydration like the things you
find ultramarathon exactly it's not
surprisingly for something that is
fraught with electricity and Spears and
you know like climbing up super tall
things and crawling barbed wire like
nobody's like lost an eye I don't think
from a barbed wire you know one of my
buddies got zapped in the eye with one
of those electrical of those electric
lines he was not he was not super happy
about that I mean the worst of the worst
extent of my injuries are really like my
body is just covered in barbed wire
scars like scratches you can probably
show you them but you know I look like I
was attacked by a tiger yeah I was
wondering what kind of cat you had
everywhere burns you know I'm never
gonna be a leg model because Fifty
Shades of tough mudder yeah the surgery
I want to talk about your knee surgery
yeah why did you get knee surgery and
let's start with that what was the what
was the reason for the knee surgery so I
um
last summer heading into like World
Championship season ended up tearing my
meniscus and that was in training right
I was in training it was like I was like
running in Chicago and they're like
potholes everywhere and there's like one
those like free is one of those freak
things where you like step in something
and you're like ah ah my leg and then
I'm like running off and like oh wait
this actually isn't okay and so you know
I went and I had an MRI I thought I was
like okay but they're like my leg kept
locking and I had to like physically
unlock it and so I think with certain
meniscus tears that happens and so they
just they had to go in there and you
know shave down the meniscus and then
there was some like to be old plateau
fracture and whatever francis so I just
had to stay off it for a bit yeah when
did you so that happened how much long
how much later did you compete
so I raced again eight weeks
post-surgery and I remember asking my
surgeon this was the world's toughest
mutter correct 2014 correct what you won
I did so I remember asking my surgeon
and I was like so how I'm talking back
Ryan he was like maybe like four weeks
and I go so could I feasibly run a race
like eight weeks later he's like yeah
and I was like how long of a race and
because he was like thinking like I was
gonna run a five to a 5k yeah I was like
why it's like 24 hours so I never got
his blessing for it but I did anyway so
what did you do
between the what steps did you take to
rehab it I mean what were the most
important things that you did I mean I I
think most importantly for me was was
getting into I like got into physical
therapy like the next day like I had the
best physical therapist in Chicago and
she was fantastic with me through other
injuries and things like that so we were
pretty aggressive and rehabbing it and
then I just did whatever else I could to
work around it stay in shape you know I
think when people get injured they
forget that there's so much that they
still can do so I had to gem that how to
ski urgh
which if you've ever seen it's like a
rower turned upside down and you pull it
like you're cross-country skiing so you
know for two weeks that was the only
like really like thing I could do to
like keep my heart rate up I'm a hand by
skiers hand bike ski argh I could roll
with one leg but they're not kind of
like throws then my other leg any
massive but you know and I would do and
I like rode a 10k on earth geared to 10k
which is the worst kind of torture you
can like do to yourself you know um and
just finding other finding other ways to
work around it what other rehab
modalities did you find most helpful
personally did a lot of like stem for to
kit because I think when you go in what
your goals to electrical stimulation
so when you go in and you like cut open
your knee or whatever it shuts down your
quad and so the main thing is getting
your quad to then come back and function
again and so stim is really helpful and
you know like retraining that to get it
to fire so that was you know that was
helpful and really like I'm a huge fan
of like a RT grasan so for those people
not from there a RT Active Release
Technique type of myofascial release
which is super depending on how you have
it done can be super unpleasant if
you're having like your so has work done
oh my god I love that pain though I
think it's like having some yeah like
therapists with their like Ridge hand
knuckle deep and you're so as I had just
as a side note alright so I'm gonna give
a shout out to this guy Jesse Burdick it
was a powerlifter who trans with a
friend of mine named Mark Bell I mean
they do a lot of training separately but
I think he pulls and Jesse I apologize
if I get this wrong but he can deadlift
more than 700 pounds yeah he's a big
unit and we were getting ready to do he
also does manual therapy so we're
getting ready to do an air tea session
and and they put him on a table I'm kind
of drapes like one leg off and he goes
the safe word is brisket and then she
just proceeds to annihilate my hips so
the basic idea folks for those of you
don't know they are tea and please
correct me if I get this wrong but if
you have it adhesions let's just say
with scar tissue between adjacent
tissues you apply pressure manual
pressure a therapist applies pressure
between those tissues then has you
perform motions like an overhead kind of
reaching movement for the lats to break
apart those adhesions graston which is
like having really thick butter knives
scraped all over you right I read that
you use something and I'm embarrassed I
actually don't know what this is dry
needling oh yeah
what is that so it's a sound term it's
apparently illegal in California which
is why you're probably it's like
acupuncture on crack so and acupuncture
is actually rightfully probably hate it
cuz I think they they think they think
it's kind of like a bastardization of
what they do but
so when you go and you get acupuncture
and the goal is like to not feel the
needle dry needling you actually are
sticking the needle in the muscle Valley
to try and get it to twitch and the
twitch is like the release so um it's
like and you don't leave the needles in
there so you're basically like poking at
a muscle just sewing a machine
yeah and the worst ever don't ever let
anybody dry a needle your calf your
gastroc because like if you get in
underneath like right and like the
hamstring insertion like you will feel
like you got shot in the back of your
legs and but it can also be kind of
addictive because like you have somebody
like poking around your glute me and you
feel this twitch and it's almost like
this like release of the muscle and what
does it do for you it is it's supposed
to you know for super tight muscles the
idea at least yeah huh so yeah I had the
I had this this nutty experience and if
people want to see photos of me and
excruciating pain getting a RT done by
Charles Poliquin you can see that in the
4-hour body it's kind of hilarious but
the itis separate experience with
something called mmm let's see I guess
it would be called a neuro puncture but
I'm I'm getting that wrong this was done
with dr. Lee Wolfe for many years ago
with shallow injections of Pirlo
solutions so yeah and what happened
though and we improvised at this point
is she was working on my infraspinatus
this is a rotator cuff muscle than all
that always get sore for me and I really
died reconstruct her shoulder surgery
and I probably sit like you know Kalaa
like chest collapsed the you know Gollum
when I'm typing also which is no good
but she was working on my infraspinatus
and she was doing the the kind of sewing
machine approach with these these
shallow injections and and we both here
and it sounded like someone was scraping
ice off a windshield and it turned out
that I had these these just this huge
clump of calcium deposits at the back of
both shoulders and so we ended up just
what we
it's a royal way she ended up using the
needle basically as a scraper to kind of
break down these calcium deposits and
what was fascinating is no shoulder pit
for months afterward after chiseling
these out wasn't the most pleasant thing
in the world to the dry needling now
that you're here in California no more
sad sad times no more glutamate pokes
yeah I go back to my black market dry
needling yeah I'll get acupuncture done
and I'm like can you guys like sin like
they'll accidentally a muscle will
trigger and release and I'm like oh
that's fantastic
I'm like I'll try anything once and you
know it's like recovery or like you know
I'll just throw that especially because
for most professional athletes that what
they do you know they their job is like
to be a professional athlete and then to
like rehab and recover it's been all
that time I'm like training early in the
mornings I go and I sit at his desk for
ten hours a day and then I like try and
like training it in the evenings like
it's not an ideal like I'm not doing my
body any favors for like what what what
is your nutrition look like and were you
serious earlier when I asked you about
breakfast what was your answer we were
doing a sound check and I asked her what
she had for breakfast was your answer no
that's actually jars has become kind of
this like running joke in the obstacle
racing community with me because when I
won the Spartan Race World Championships
in 2013 I was so far ahead I was like
twenty thirty minutes ahead of the next
woman and the race director yells out at
me he goes million what'd you have for
breakfast this morning and I'm like
pop-tarts and I actually did randomly
that day because they're really good
source of easy easy
Miller digestible carbs Billie that's it
what's that you said or do you say your
full-name sorry i sorry said amelia
okay got it sometimes I can't say my own
name and so it kind of became this thing
that like I would just like pre-race
ritual
that would be like a good luck thing
tonight sure a pop-tart because I'm a
soup I'm a really big person into
superstition and it's kind of grown from
there and now I see like I was at I was
at a race the other weekend and like
everyone around me was eating pop tarted
like why of them eating pop charts and
like they tagged me in it and I'm like
oh my god I've created a monster this
actually could be an incredible
opportunity for you to do whatever you
want because I remember watching pumping
iron and arles person hangers talking
about the guys who come up to him and
ask him for advice and it gives them the
wrong advices and he would like tell
them to go into the shower at the gym
and like scream all their posing see you
could you could actually you could pull
an incredible April Fool's joke but
announce it a year later after everyone
has already embraced it what other
superstitions do you have not limited to
racing necessarily yeah I'm one of those
people that so it's the same like I will
wear the same sports bra like so we
raised pretty much like sports bra and
like compression shorts because you want
as little clothing to like hold down the
mud as possible so I'll wear the same
you know if I did well in a race like
I'll wear the same outfit for like the
next race and especially the same
headband and then if I don't do well
then that one gets discarded you know
and so it's it's that kind of like your
typical sports stuff I actually have
this is kind of embarrassing but a small
little stuffed dog that travels with me
to all races and because I'm typically
by myself and really cheap sketchy
hotels because these races are like in
the middle of nowhere so it's like my
little guard dog how big is the stuff
that oh it's like where did you get that
as a protection does it gir a guardian
as a guard dog
so yeah I mean it's it's just it's it's
silly it's silly stuff like that outside
of pop-tarts yeah what is what is your
let's just say you're four weeks out
from a race yeah what is your what does
a day of food look like for you honestly
like it's one of those things I've
struggled with that I've tried every
like I tried to do paleo I tried to be
like maybe I can become a fat adapted
athlete because for longer races I
didn't want to have to like rely on gels
gels stuff like that because after a
while it can it can be too much in your
stomach but I just never I'm never gonna
be the paradigm of good eating of like
and and I couldn't couldn't stick with
like you know the whole like you know
trying to I couldn't go far enough into
like the fat apt at Asian like it was
just miserable I like ice cream way too
much it's somewhat contraindicated for
ketosis and much to my chagrin I think I
realized I'm like you know I'm I'm
performing well um I'm winning races so
why change if it gets to the point where
I'm not doing performing then then I'll
take another look at my diet and switch
it but at this point it's like I run so
much I put in so much you know time that
I'm like whatever I enjoy food and all
eat kind of whatever
what do you consume during a 24 hour
race what is your game this is actually
a question from a fan yeah which was how
does your gear that you bring with you
differ in an obstacle course race versus
an ultramarathon
instance yeah besides how the wet see it
yeah so I think it really depends if
you're running I've as I've learned from
like dabbling and ultramarathons is that
my body does it especially if you're
running hard I'm my body isn't gonna
handle solid food as well it's like the
stomach will like stomach acid and stuff
like that so there's a lot of like
liquid-like tailwind is a good you know
something that a lot of people use to
like that it's really easy on your
stomach element that's a good name yeah
yeah and so but I also just find you
know like simple I actually really love
like um like I like chewing on things
like like cliff makes these blocks so
you know like I do I take in simple
sugars that that like fuel me through
that
I love how often do you eat during a 24
hour race I try and fuel every like I
try and fuel every 30 minutes an hour
get something in but little bits and
then I'm telling you sometimes are the
best things during like a long race are
like oh god I had a Krispy Kreme donut
during the world's toughest motor this
past year and it was like the most
phenomenal thing I never had salty
things you know like you want to make
sure that you like you your electrolytes
okay especially if you're running in a
wetsuit because you're loose I mean you
must be losing some ins it's such
incredible amount of fluids yeah I mean
so pickle juice mustard things like that
do you carry that with you their
stations regardless there are stations
there are imagining like a Camelback
that's full of pickle juice well I
actually do I carry mustard packets with
me well small packets so cuz vinegar is
if you ever have issues with cramping
you know they say that like the vinegar
the salt and stuff like that can pickle
juice as well no no stop cramps in their
tracks
pickle juice yes was that make sense
yeah I mean it's a pickle juice is
harder to carry with you yes you have
like a little vial or something like
that but yeah so I think that for the
longer the race gets you obviously need
more gear and especially depending on
like the cold and the weather and what
your conditions are and so you know
sometimes it's it's pretty massive the
you mentioning electrolytes it's it's
fascinating when you look at sort of the
record of
health issues in endurance races most
people assume that a lot of it would be
related to dehydration but oftentimes
it's a complete opposite yeah where a
lot of people the many people consume
too much water and rank it I guess it's
like it did hypernatremia where you
dilute sodium to the extent that in some
cases your heart stops functioning yeah
and the I recall I was doing this
kettlebell certification years ago and
it was just like thousands and thousands
of swings and whatnot outside in
Minnesota and people were getting
horrible cramps and they're like oh
we're not drinking enough water and
eating more I'm like no that's not the
issue
you need some potassium tablets and it's
but God that could be the worst I mean
do people I would imagine you there must
be a fair number of competitors who just
have to drop out because they get like
quater or hamstring cramps or is that
cramps can be like super debilitating
and I think and especially like in
really hot races and and also in really
cold races some like the extremes so
that you know it happens it's the reason
why the longer the race is to get you
know like the more unknown and things
like that
go into it and so it can be it's always
kind of a crapshoot you know like you're
like come on body please cooperate with
me this one time but sometimes you can't
you can't predict it so what what
supplements do you use on daily basis I
like coffee so I am actually really have
really kind of bought that hype and the
science behind beeps beats yeah so I
actually I work with a company called
beat elite which is it's powdered beat
concentrated beat and so it's really
that like if you I remember the first
time I ever had beet juice which just
tastes like death like yeah I mean I I
some people like beet juice but I I
can't handle it but like you feel this
weird like head rush almost and so I was
like well there might be something to
this [ __ ] so it's uh so I am really it's
something that I actually like drink
ever like before workouts and stuff like
that and you
delivers and the nitric oxide to help
the breathing and everything like that
so I think for endurance athletes you
don't need I don't need the massive dose
of caffeine before I go out you know and
run because who wants to be jittery
while like you know running for several
hours you need more of like the the like
the help with the breathing and keeping
the heart rate low and stuff like that
and then I also take you know I try to
stay away from like anti-inflammatories
like Advil and stuff like that just
because you know it's it's hard on the
body but big believer in like tumeric
yeah um and other things like that then
anything to try and help with like bones
and joints and so you're just taking a
look like glucosamine or MSM or whatever
but I try and get in natural I'm like uh
like bone broth and gelatin and things
like that you know but it's bone broth
is an expensive habit until I like bite
the bullet and make my own but then I
have to like handle chicken feet and not
really into that so you're in a good
place for the for the bone broth I'm in
the Bay Area I was like it was a three
stone hearth I think in Berkeley yeah
further down the peninsula you got some
really good sources as well right
fortunately yeah hippies love bone broth
oh it's the new thing and for anybody in
New York I'll just give a shout out to a
new I guess it's kind of a side gig
started by a chef friend of mine Marco
Canora who was in the 4-hour chef brodo
they serve hot bone broth in the winters
in New York City BR o dó it's amazing
and you can get turmeric and/or Cuban
different flavored actually yeah you get
that you can you can pay for the add-ons
what is your prehab routine look like so
the exercise is what exercises do you do
to prevent injuries yes so the main
injuries that I've kind of dealt with
have always been kind of revolving like
hips and you know glutes and like most
runners glutes that don't fire so like I
yeah I renew yeah yeah exactly
so uh that like Jane Fonda's are the you
know the the gold standard but it is
it's a lot of like kind of like
stability work so I try and do a lot of
single leg stuff what type of single leg
stuff uh so single leg squats you know
you don't you see like CrossFitters do
you like pistols all the way like a
stick around you don't need to do that
kind of stuff you know just like small
little like you know mini single leg
squats I try into like whenever I'm
standing around I'm trying to like just
stand like on one leg like balancing and
things like that um I do a lot of like
band you know like the the physio band
like walks so like monster walks right
here yeah the Xbox that's that kind of
stuff and then a lot of work especially
it was a trail runner you really want to
work like your what is your transverse
abdominus or like those really deep core
core corset muscle yeah yeah so a lot of
exercises that will like engage that you
know like bird dogs and things like that
just their I mean they're they're
they're super like not fun and little
tiny movements but I think most people
would rather go like you know squat 200
pounds and ignore those and that's not
gonna help you so you're working on glue
being doing sort of ice lateral or
single leg movements do you do step ups
any work on boxes I do um I do too I
think I think and like lunges things
like that
anything that's requiring you to that is
required yeah that like unilateral
movement to some and how much time would
you say you spend on those types of
prehab movements on a weekly basis it's
prob about 15 to 20 minutes a day okay
15 20 and you do that pre-workout is it
a separate workout or after it's
generally like I'll do a few like
activation um one you know like fire
hydrants before and then after it's
generally afterwards that all kind of
devote 15-20 minutes
to kind of that those like small little
strengthening baby exercises and how
many miles on average do you run per
week she's changed a lot I used to a few
years ago I actually didn't really put
in that much mileage I was like you know
running too much it's not good for you
or whatever I did I switched my training
from to be more running intensive
because I realized that if you're gonna
run for 24 hours she probably should be
good at running yeah right exactly
because I was used to joke I'm like I'm
not a runner but then I realized that I
actually I love running on trails and I
love long long runs and so now I'm
probably putting in probably about 6070
miles a week which actually is not that
much for a lot of you see a lot of
runners who put in like 100 mile weeks
button 6070 miles away yeah and how much
time do you spend doing other types of
training like weight training or
otherwise yeah I do so I used to I I do
I generally will like CrossFit three to
four days a week so you know or some
kind of bastardized version of my own if
I'm not actually gonna make it to a
CrossFit gym it's also because I kind of
pick and choose what I like to do from
that so I mean I guess it would be
probably I know five to six other hours
of other strength training like interval
training and things like that
what is your morning routine or routines
look like first first sixty minutes of
your day so you wake up yeah punch the
Roosters make them crow where I am what
happens to you what is your what does
your day look like between say 4 and
5:30 yeah I mean I wish I could give you
an answer that's like you know I go out
and I do Sun Salutations or like
breathing exercises or whatever well the
sun's not even out of that hour but it's
nothing really it's nothing really that
interesting I mean I wake up you know
generally at that point I'll actually
typically answer some work emails that
since I go to bed pretty early what time
you go to bed probably I try and get
about by 9:00 so sometimes I'll work
emails that will come in like later than
that so I'll answer those and then I'm
just you know gathering everything up
and heading out to if I'm going the gym
that day or if I'm hitting up the trails
that day so because all typically I'll
train in the morning and then I'll get
ready and go straight into work the time
you get to work about 7:30 or so mm-hmm
and so know if you eaten breakfast at
this point or no I will eat so gently so
wake up charts just race days and this
morning because this is the only thing
the trunk of my car as I was driving up
here um pop-tarts in the trunk of my car
but no also I'll generally wake up and I
actually typically eat a few spoonfuls
of like nut butter to fuel before I go
out for like if I'm gonna go run you
know 10 15 miles it's a good source of
you know fuel to keep me going she'll
just have like a few tablespoons of
almond butter or something like that
pretty much hmm and uh and then I yeah
and I found out that you know sits well
and then I'll eat breakfast after I
train and then get to the office things
like that so what does a non pop-tart
breakfast
generally I'm a big fan of like omelets
and eggs and things like that in the
morning mainly because I really like
ketchup and I always put ketchup on it
that's just a vehicle for the ketchup
pretty much a few cents it's sugar theme
going on here
let's don't take diet advice from a
million I want to just take perhaps a
few of these fan questions yeah and
we've hit on number of them already
but you know I had fans but yes you did
come from Scott uh you have a lot of
fans among my fans I see that this is a
question
then I'd be interested to hear the
answer as well this is from Cindy Paula
Wien I'm probably masking that what is
what is your self talk during training
and during the challenges sound like the
moment when you want to quit now just to
head this off at the pass the the answer
may be that you don't feel yeah like you
want to quit but during it extremely
hard races or challenging times
what is your self-talk yeah look like so
I found like many athletes and maybe not
you but have sort of consistent routines
in terms of their self-talk so what's
interesting especially with long races
that you're always going to hit a low
part it's like and if there's always
going to be a part where you want to
quit you know 24 hours at like and for
me it generally comes early it's like
four hours in and I'm like god I got to
do it this first you know the Sun
setting and it's getting cold the winds
picking up there's a massive sandstorm
whatever for me I think I generally it's
hard because people talk ask me about
self-talk I generally just shut my brain
off and I feel like that that's what
keeps I don't I don't really think about
anything but I think when has that
always been the case I think so I think
that do you just will that into being I
think I just kind of go I well I use
different coping techniques I sing to
myself a lot when I'm out there please
tell me you sing out loud sometimes yes
really yeah if I have if I'm not if I
have enough breath like you know so yeah
you know I there will be like a there
will be like a certain song for every
race that will just kind of like replay
through my head so 2012 world's toughest
Mudder was macklemore's thrift shop it
was a great before it hit big no like
right before it like busted out like and
I swear to God I sing that song over and
over again I can't listen to it the same
way
but what other songs is so those like
your mantra
it was Macklemore was like your
meditative mantra pretty much 24 hours
24 hours that's dedication what other
songs have you used oh god they ranged
like all over the place
sometimes it's sometimes it's just like
all kind of like seeing sometimes it'll
be like a so my favorite hymn ever is I
was raised Catholic and whatever and I
love you know I've always loved church
music so there's a Christmas song like
lo how a rose air blooming it's like an
old hymn not at all what you would think
would be like running through my head
like running a race sometimes it does
you know and but then this other race it
was Kanye it was like Kanye's monster it
was like the song was called monster you
know so what did do other racers do that
as well they are aware of or do do you
do any other top racers have coping
approaches that you think are
interesting you know I think that a lot
of people have like that self-talk like
I've always tried to you and I think
this is pretty common set like a lot of
us will try and break up the race into
small segments because if you look at
the whole picture it will get
overwhelming if you're like I have a
hundred miles to run and you're like
crap you know but if you're like no I
only have three miles or I'm just gonna
focus on getting through these next ten
minutes and so I've always found that a
lot of people who do long endurance
events will break it up into small
manageable chunks you know and just
focus on the next few minutes ahead of
them mm-hm and I think that works pretty
well do you I mean it sounds like you
probably have some form of meditation
when you run and I think that in terms
of just mindfulness I'm sure it's right
a very present state of where to start
with but do you have a separate
meditative practice if anytime I don't
I've tried I went to this like retreat
that was fantastic and I tried to do
this meditation session and I just like
20 minutes in I was like I got it move
and do something and get out of here so
for me it's almost like the meditation
is like is is working really hard like
you know like sprinting or running or
lifting heavy weights like that's like
my yoga practice you know uh no I don't
know what this refers to but since well
Hicks is asking are you going to do the
24-hour battle frog in March does that
mean anything to you it does okay it's
it's a race it's another 24-hour
obstacle race you know maybe I don't
know my my schedule next year's is kind
of up in the air I really I really want
to kind of like venture and challenge
like myself in new ways and so I think
I'm gonna be doing a lot more like pure
trail races to which I haven't really
had a chance especially to out being out
here in California you know it's a much
better like I love climbing running up
mountains and some like that so why did
you decide to move to California um a
variety of reasons I think the main was
I'm from the west coast I want to get
back here and then it was a time for a
transition in a career for me you know
I'd been at a law firm for six years and
it was great and they were fantastic but
kind of wanted to try a new like you
know going in house and working working
for a company there and and then I
actually I'll be honest that totally the
training and having mountains and hills
around me it was really hard I am the
happiest when I am out on a mountain
running around somewhere and I couldn't
do that in Chicago so are you able to
disclose the company that you're working
for yeah yes a little company you may
have heard of it maybe not I work for
Apple yeah
it's a good company I have a lot of a
lot of friends at the mothership that's
fun to make sure they would allow you to
like my LinkedIn and Facebook profile
okay
it's public this is a very racing
specific question Stephen Vicki how do
you keep your body limber after ice or
water immersion during a race keep
moving
just keep moving I mean because yeah
yeah otherwise if you slow down that's
when your body temperature goes down and
then you're gonna get hypothermic mm-hmm
let's let's uh let's go to the third act
okay which is rapid-fire questions they
don't have to be rapid-fire answers but
the word successful and you hear the
word successful who is the first person
who comes to mind and why it's so hard
because I didn't meet your typical
lawyer answer where I'm like well
because successful can have so many
different definitions no no that's fair
though yeah but just just yeah sort of
reflexively so this is gonna be kind of
a strange answer probably but I always
find people who have like transitioned
their careers throughout their who've
had like who I guess who've been
flexible in their careers and who have
transitioned notice that the answers not
coming all right okay here we go
I'm gonna use an example do that all the
time don't worry ass trying to record
like a 20-second intro for this little
audio book yesterday and it probably
took me 47 takes so the example yeah so
I'm going to give you an example of a
person who I've been successful and then
I'll explain why perfect um Triple H
Triple H so I am a huge wrestling fan
huge professional wrestling fan and the
reason why I'm gonna use and I could use
I could use a number of people as this
example but the reason that I'm gonna
use this is because I find people who
have had like one who so he had a very
successful wrestling career but then
transitioned into the business aspect of
it you find so many people on it this is
interesting being in I guess you could
tag
you call me kind of a professional
athlete you see a lot of people who I
find are very kind of short-sighted in
that in that they're like well I you
know I'm racing now and that but they
don't think about what happens when they
can no longer do that so people who have
been able to have a very successful
athletic career and then transition into
the business side of things or to think
far ahead you know and so those are the
people that I look to that I'm like you
know they have they have everything they
have they let excite of it but then they
also have the business acumen and are
smart enough to know that their body
isn't going to loss from there for them
you know Oscar De La Hoya a good example
to the Golden Boy Productions right very
savvy I mean if we want to keep going
professional wrestling you know it's
like the rock you know like things got
transferred after he's done all right so
Triple H is a great example that is Paul
Levesque a really smart guy I had him on
the podcast listen I just blew my mind
really really right right okay so Triple
H I I agree
I also view him he works out it I think
midnight every day day with Joe DeFranco
like after his entire is very opposite
schedules but he's also a big fan of
routine and which I know and I've heard
him talk about too and and that's how I
get by and like I don't care where I am
in life if I'm traveling if I'm on the
road for work like I'm going to create a
routine there and stick with it you know
and so that's nice but what is something
that you believe that other people think
is insane or any controversial beliefs
that you have and if nothing jumps to
mind we can also come back to that hmm
yeah I may come back to that one okay
we'll come back to that what book or
books have you gifted most to other
people
I'm gonna butcher this author's name
because I always do um house of leaves
by mark so blue mark Daniel Daniel loose
key so in the reason that I say this and
that I and that I would give this is
that so so many people now read on like
Kindles or technology or things like
that
this is a book that you have to hold
because there are parts of it where you
need to turn it upside down to read it
and I forget the style of what it's
called the style of writing there's
actual eggs on report but like there are
certain pages where you are reading it
and it turns in a circle so it's in like
an entire I think that reading a book
and you know holding the physical book
and turning the pages is such a lost art
you know and so there's something but
this is a book that's like an entire
sensory experience it's a fantastic
story it's brilliant it's kind of like a
story within a story but then it
requires you as a reader to be like
active and involved you know and I think
that's just so cool because you don't
see stuff like that anymore and
especially now when people read things
on you know their iPads or their Kindles
or whatever and kind of like holding a
book is something that we no longer do
so house of leaves very cool give any
favorite documentaries or movies my
all-time favorite movies The Goonies The
Goonies
I mean it's quality film it's not it's
not gonna like it's not life-changing
but you know inside any favorite
character from The Goonies um
data data data is great power I mean
like yeah I've grown up in Oregon you
just had to like that was that was my
jamm you know we didn't have much to
claim being from Oregon but we could
claim that movie
what is the purchase that is most for
less than $100 purchase of less than
hundred dollars that is most positively
impacted your life in recent memory
so manuka honey bandages and so I get
banged up a lot racing yep see ya
there's for the photos that you sent me
so before you do these interviews I ask
for short bio some photos that might be
usable and I'm looking at one of them
you're climbing up this red and you're
just covered in blood so yes you get
banged up so this past summer I actually
there's this one obstacle called
rolling traverse where you babysit
called Tyrolean Traverse Tyrolean yeah
so it's like you've seen like the
military guys they like it's a rope then
you either go under it it's just a rope
traverse yeah but you can also go on top
of it it saves your trip and I decided
one day one race to go on top of it
saving my grip and I was wearing just a
sports bra and massive rope burn all
down the front of my and like the worst
pain was like a second-degree burn and I
discovered that the only thing that
would take away the steam were these
like honey bandages and there was only
CBS was the only place that sold them
CBS has manuka honey bandages the only
because or I could find them online too
and uh I swear is the only thing that
got me through like the next few weeks
in like no pain but now I use them all
the time for all of like my scrapes and
it's they're great like antibacterial
and blah blah I mean with a number that
I bought I'm sure it's over I've spent
way more than a hundred dollars on them
but the new kinda been just cool now I
usually ask about morning routines
already covered quite a bit of that what
other routines or habits do you find
important in your day or week um I it's
very easy for me to or I think it's very
easy for a lot of people to get
disconnected from you know people around
especially now in our like social media
type of world is that like you you know
like something on
scram or you know favorite something on
Twitter or whatever you whatever the
things are that you do so it's very
important for me to like I always set a
time every single week and I call my
parents like at the same time and I call
my sister and to try and make those
those you know personal connections and
stuff like that because it can be so
impersonal now with everything that we
have you know technology that you can be
like friends with people that you've
never met in real life so I always try
like for me that routine like every
Sunday at the same time calling the
parents you know just kind of like keep
me grounded things like that do you have
any wind down routine what is the hour
before bed look like I so I generally
can't wait to hear this no I was just
like I'm just trying to think of like if
I actually had because generally I'll be
um you know watching Monday Night Raw I
don't watch a lot of TV but it's either
sports or professional wrestling what I
do you know I I am generally one of
those people that's like so tired by the
time it's time to go to bed I don't
really need a routine don't have it it's
just assess it II it's like alright it's
time to go to bed on it cold
got it if you could have a billboard
anywhere what would it say put anything
on it
I think I would say I think would be
something along the lines of no one owes
you anything
hmm and I think that this has been
something that lately I feel like
there's such a level of entitlement now
in people like that that
oh I deserve this or I blow all of this
and at the end of the day I'm like it's
hard work you know the people that I
find the most successful people that I
that one thing that I've always prided
myself on is that like I've worked
really goddamn hard for everything that
you know that I've gotten or that I've
done in my life
and you can't expect handouts from
people you know the at the end of the
day all that you can that you can count
on really is yourself and so like I
don't expect people to give me anything
so and I really wish like you know so
you see people now like I don't know the
level of entitlement that people think
that they deserve a handout or deserve
help sometimes sometimes I'm like no
make it yourself make your own
opportunities
you know yep that's very pronounced here
in Silicon Valley - it's like I know you
just had a great idea when you went to
the bathroom but it's not worth fifty
million dollars yet I'm sorry
this is this is not one of my normal
rapid-fire questions and I'm sure I'm
gonna get a lot of grief for this from
my fans but I have to ask because I know
a lot of very successful women CEOs and
so on I see 2012 second place overall I
mean you could have potentially I mean
it's well within their all possibility
you could have won the whole thing
do you find it hard to date is it I mean
is it because I'm imagining if I put
myself in your shoes
it must be and Urich's in your extremely
successful in your career is it hard for
you to find someone you respect enough
to date because I mean in like the
mental physical emotional toughness
high-dose fears so I don't think that is
so much me I
I honestly hi so I tend to be attracted
to people that are almost like I don't
say the exact opposite than me because
then that sounds like I'm attracted to
people who are like aren't successful
but what I found is that I need somebody
who's very complementary to me in terms
of like very kind of I admire people
that are super laid back and go with the
flow and very adaptable and just you
know everything that I'm not
and so I think that like for me it's not
so hard to find people like that I think
though you know sometimes you do get
you'll hear you know it takes a certain
type of guy who can be secure with with
being with you know a woman who you know
beats 99% of the dudes out like good
sport or whatever and that feels weird
to say that feels like I'm like being
like look at me I'm sacs of the facts
but you know it's I think that it takes
actually a guy who's very secure in his
own right you know you can't I can't
like date somebody who's like who's not
um you know secure in who he is because
then that would just be disastrous
that's like it would get very far what
what advice would you give your 25 year
old self and place place us 20 and 25
I'd be interested to get it for both
edges so wait where were you what you
were doing at 20 and then 25 so 20 I was
finishing up college probably just
getting ready to apply to law school
super you know like hardcore driven
going to be partner at a law firm one
day you know like all those things
um I think at that time I would tell
myself to relax and you know that you
can't predict where life is going to
take you
and because now looking I'm like what I
ever expected I'd be like the world's
top obstacle racer we don't even know
what the [ __ ] obstacle it wasn't even
around that thing wasn't even a thing
and so and I think at 25 I was finishing
up law school and I was starting my
career as an attorney um so it's
probably similar but I think what I
would tell I'm actually gonna give you I
would I would tell my 28 year old self
which is when I started all of this
obstacle racing stuff and I would tell
myself it really doesn't matter at the
end of the okay that sounds bad but like
don't take it so seriously you know and
at the end of racing itself the racing
itself because when you reach it started
out as totally fun and then you reach a
certain level of success and everyone
then it becomes this pressure and
everything like that and I think that
it's not all the stress and the pressure
and everything that I would put on
myself from it it's it's not worth it
doesn't change the outcome I'm either
you know ready or I'm not to like you
know beat somebody so at the end of the
day kind of keep it all in perspective
and like it's kind of hilarious I'm
running around in the mud being shocked
by electrical things like running around
for 24 hours in a wetsuit like just keep
that in perspective it's kind of
ludicrous of what I'm doing you know so
have fun with it
you know cuz there's so much time that I
think that it wasted not like putting so
much pressure on myself and not having
fun and now I've kind of like come full
circle oh my god it's just fun you know
who would you who is someone or who are
people you would like to meet someday if
any are see that like this is like
massive you know whose news is up at the
top of the list
Ronda Rousey Ronda Rousey I like to meet
strong I have an entire list like strong
females who are like the top of what
they do she's on my list too right but
then I that also extends to you know
just the other things that are like not
athletic
ly inclined you know so you see like
Sheryl Sandberg in like the the females
that have made names for themselves and
you know as top executives and things
like that so I'm not like rah-rah girl
power type of person but you know
finding other women like that and seeing
what makes them tick and seeing how they
survive is is always really interesting
for me what if any asks or requests do
you have for the audience and this is
the this is the last question yeah
anything you'd like them to do or think
about or consider or all the above right
you know I think one of the things that
I've learned is like and what I would
tell people is like be open to
experiences you know and especially with
their probably likes to do people if
they're sitting here listening this or
either already an obstacle course racing
and are like man this shit's bananas
it's great you know so I don't need to
convince them of anything or if they've
happened upon this and they're like we
don't understand what this chick is
doing actually like I don't know I would
say go out there and like you know try
something new and you know so if that's
up if you want to go out and run off
school right of course like great but I
want to be where I am today without you
know just like saying sure and trying
something and and seeing where that
leads me so I think that's always kind
of important to keep in mind try
something new yeah it's good advice do
something asking them to do something
that well I think it's good good advice
I mean do something just for the [ __ ] of
it I think it's kind of right coming
back to your don't take it so sir
like not everything has to figure into
your five year right plan and I think
that's hard because for me it's like
I've always been not like super plan or
five year person so it's something that
I actually have to remind myself is like
try something new Amelia like just do it
yeah why not do it those that was one of
my I can call it a resolution so it
wasn't a New Year's resolution but when
I've done did a lot of unusual
experiments last year right now
but one of the one of the realizations
was be playful like you don't have to be
so goddamn serious about things all the
time I mean this like do something that
doesn't have an explicit point or an
angle or whatever it might be if
somebody told me the other day um that
the only thing at the end of the day the
only thing we have is time if you really
cut through all the [ __ ] out there
and like this is funny when you asked me
about like who do you think is
successful and like seriously I think
the most successful people who are out
there are people that are happy that are
just like they may not have it out they
may be dirt poor they may not be
educated they may whatever but if they
can art everyday life smiling and just
generally happy like when if you break
it all down all we have is time so why
spend it being miserable so like go do
something that makes you happy and like
and have fun with it because you're not
taking it with you when you go you're
your most valuable non-renewable
resource exactly as far as we know when
my time finally comes and I realize that
there's like a supercool world on the
other side I'm gonna be like goddamn
well Amelia thanks so much for taking
the time and we're working people say
hello find you on the interwebs and so
on on my grossly needs updating website
Amelia been racing calm but I actually
am most active on Twitter it's just the
handles Amelia Boone Vinnie I'm Boone
Athenian at the end
Amelia Boone Bo and II correct but you
fair
I tweet a fair amount about the Seahawks
and professional wrestling so if you're
not into that you probably don't have
follow me and then i'm on instagram as
well it's a AR boon 11 because emily
button was already taken by the time I
joined them they are Boone 11 correct
um and I'm on Facebook I don't have an
athlete page because I don't really like
that or believe in that but you can
follow me but I don't really become
friends with people I haven't met before
in life because that weirds me out
it's a Twitter so Twitter and Instagram
are your best that's what Instagram cool
well this has been a blast yeah
everybody listening we will link to the
books and so on the manuka honey
bandages and whatnot everything
mentioned in the show notes you can just
go to 4-hour workweek comm all spelled
out forward slash podcast and that will
have all episodes including this one and
i'll create just short short link you
can go to or it's not a short link but a
URL you can go to 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash amelia and that will go
straight to this episode and amelia once
again thank you so much for taking time
and i would say let's go for a run some
time but i have some training to do
before I'm prepared for that and
everybody listening as always thank you
so much for sticking around and we'll
see you soon
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday the vet provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business is a logo
website business card thumbnail or any
other design I recommend checking out
99designs
I use them myself I've used them for
many years I use them to create book
cover prototypes for the 4-hour body
which went on to becoming number one
York Times best seller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
com forward slash 10th
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth run so the question is why why is
it so popular why is it unique because
you can get services previously reserved
for the ultra wealthy but only pay
pennies on the dollar for them and this
is because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
take the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they'd put you in and if you just want
to take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it here's why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user
and have them on the podcast but I've
been so impressed by wealthfront that
I've invested a significant amount of my
own money at least for me in the team
and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of now I do have to
read a mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there's the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim and until next
time thank you for listening